bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de l'iphone on va parler des iphone pour
savoir quel iphone choisir en 2018 parce
qu'il ya énormément d'iphone au
catalogue d'apple
renault n'a jamais eu autant donc la
question se pose si vous voulez acheter
un iphone si vous voulez changer
passer d'un android et ios il va falloir
se poser la bonne question quel iphone
choisir et on y va
[Musique]
les iphone il y en a de tous les côtés y
en a même peut-être trop il ya tellement
de choix qu'on s'y faire un peu qu'on
sait plus quel acheter donc si vous
n'êtes pas forcément hyper qu'elle est
chez les dans les produits apple en tout
cas du côté des iphone et j'ai essayé de
vous aider dans cette vidéo il donnait
un peu les bonnes astuces
alors avant toute chose avant de
commencer je voulais vous remercier pour
tous vos commentaires que je lis le
rendement serait que j'ai pas trop trop
trop le temps d'y répondre mais je vais
vraiment prendre plus de temps là c'est
les vacances vont loin moi j'aime dégage
un peu plus de temps est vraiment
pouvoir vous répondre je veux vraiment
remercier parce que vous êtes très
nombreux à l'est c'est plein de messages
des messages adorables
elle a certains qui le sont un peu moins
mais c'est pas grave en tout cas mais
cela pour faire avancer un peu le débat
donc voilà je voulais vraiment vous
remercier et aussi m'excuser pour ces
questions d'autofocus sur les dernières
vidéos que j'ai fait c'est vrai que j'ai
une nouvelle caméra il ya encore des
points d'amélioration
l'autofocus du jazz 5 c'est pas
exceptionnel
ça marche pas mal donc là j'ai encore
fait de nouveaux réglages normalement je
regarde là tout mon côté normalement je
devrais pas trop perdre le point à 6
lâche un peu flou voilà j'ai essayé de
rester au centre et normalement ça
devrait aller donc voilà donc c'était un
petit peu pour vous faire un petit pot
dès le départ donc on va se concentrer
maintenant sur les iphone on va parler
des iphone il ya énormément de produits
au catalogue d'apple alors je vais vous
parler uniquement des produits neufs va
pas de reconditionner des prix
d'occasion tout simplement parce que
apple a reconnu officiellement qu'il
faisait exprès de ralentir les anciens
modèles pour économiser la batterie
si vous faites vos mises à jour de toute
façon les iphone que vous allez acheter
d'occasion ou reconditionnés vont
forcément ramener en tout cas y ont
beaucoup moins vu qu'ils seront moins
moins bon et moins performant donc je
vous conseille vraiment pas d'aller sur
des produits reconditionnés ou des pros
d'occasion en tout cas chez apple
donc ça ça a le mérite d'être clair donc
au catalogue maintenant on a plusieurs
produits
le s e 6 aces 6 aces +77 +88 plus et
l'iphone disent donc on a vraiment une
grande grande gamme alors ce que j'ai
fait dans cette vidéo c'est que je vais
essayer un peu de de schématiser de voir
quelles sont vraiment les points forts
si vous devez aller sur un iphone a
plutôt qu'un autre
bien pour quelle raison est ce que vous
devez y aller et à la fin pour condé
une vision assez claire si on commence à
prendre tous les points techniques
regarder vraiment les fiches techniques
on va s'y perd on va jamais s'en sortir
donc on va vraiment sortir le meilleur
et les chances de chaque iphone pour
voir au final quel iphone acheté en 2018
alors on va commencer tout de suite par
l'iphone et ce et comme d'habitude je
fais appel à mon ami le petit carnet
janvier j'ai pris toutes mes notes
j'ai bien travaillé suis très scolaire
vous allez voir alors est-ce que la mise
au point marche
il est mois ci des ça décroche un peu
s'améliorer alors l'iphone et ce alors
pour moi il ya trois éléments regarder
principalement quand on va choisir un
smartphone et surtout un iphone la
taille de l'écran
la qualité des photos et de la vidéo et
enfin le prix parce que ce qu'on fait en
vérité avec nos smartphones aujourd'hui
effectivement on passe des appels on la
désigne mélange des applications mais
surtout on fait des photos et c'est là
dessus que va se faire un peu la
différence
mise à part à l'iphone 10 qui offre un
écran quand même supérieur
sinon tout le reste c'est du lcd c'est
de la technologie ip est ce donc ça
marche bien
ces technologies qui sont éprouvés mais
ce ne sont pas aujourd'hui les
meilleures technologies qu'on puisse
avoir d'ailleurs dans cette vidéo je
vous invite tous les liens pour ses
produits aux descriptions s'il y en a un
qui vous intéressent que vous souhaitez
acheter vous invite à passer par un de
ces liens se sont des liens
d'affiliation effectivement sur lequel
je serai commissionné ce qui permettra
de faire évoluer la chaîne de financer
des voyages d'émeutes ayant fait les
choses comme ça donc si ça vous
intéresse n'hésitez pas à passer par là
et merci par avance
pour moi l'iphone est ce c'est vraiment
le produit compact c'est le petit iphone
un écran 4 pouces le plus petit de tous
les écrans qu'on va trouver chez apple
pour ceux qui veulent un iphone qui
aiment ce petit format
l'iphone est ce c'est parfait on
retrouve sensiblement les mêmes
caractéristiques qu'on peut avoir dans
l'iphone 6 s si ce n'est l'appareil
photo avant 1 2 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de 2.4 qui est vraiment plus
mauvaise que le seuil de l'iphone 6 s
alors il est plus mauvaise parce qu'on
peut pas dire que celle de l'iphone 6
aces soit meilleure qualité de la caméra
avance c'est pas génial
la can et arrière c'est la même c'est
une 12 mégapixels avec une ouverture de
deux points 2 bon ça fonctionne ça fait
des photos des vidéos correct c'est pas
extraordinaire mais je vous dis pour
avoir un format compact un format qui
est cohérent un format qui tient la
route
bon ça marche ça fait l affaire si vous
voulez faire de la vidéo vous faut
tourner enquête cas à 30 images par
seconde et en full hd
en 30 images ou à 60 images par seconde
et c'est un produit qui est vendu à
partir de 419 euros de l'iphone est ce
c'est vraiment le produit d'entrée de
gamme de chez apple ensuite on passe
aussi cesse et 6 s plus alors pour moi
les iphone 6 s et 6 et plus sont des
évolutions
grosso modo de l'iphone et ce dans cette
gamme je compare pas que les anciens
modèles donc on reste vraiment dans
cette gamme vendus par apple aujourd'hui
l'iphone 6 aces un plus grand écran
l'iphone 16 plus encore un plus grand
écran 4,7 pouces pour l'iphone 6 aces et
5 25 pouces pour l'iphone 6 aces plus
alors l'appareil photo arrière c'est le
même que l'iphone est ce sauf que sur
l'iphone 6 aces plus vous allez avoir en
plus une stabilisation optique donc pour
vos vidéos et pour vos photos ça devrait
un petit peu vous corrigez les
tremblements la caméra avant c'est une 5
mégapixels avec une ouverture de 2.26
iphone 6 s et 6 aces plus n'ont rien
d'extraordinaire sont des plus roses
iphone par rapport aux est ce les
caractéristiques techniques sont
corrects qui vous permet d'avoir un
iphone dans des dimensions standard mais
que ce soit sur la photo ou la vidéo
c'est pas génial
alors moi justement c'est ce que je sais
vraiment comment il fonctionne mais bon
ça fait le job je ne vais pas dire que
c'est mauvais mais pour le prix l'iphone
6 16 coûte quand même 529 euros et
l'iphone 6 aces plus 639 euros
donc bon il ya quand même un certain
budget et mon avis quitte à mettre de
l'argent
mieux vaut passer sur le set 7 plus
souple e7 est au prix du 6 s plus après
j'ai réalisé entièrement de la vidéo de
blog du hellfest sur l'iphone 6 s
[Musique]
franchement le rendu est correct on va
pas non plus dire n'importe quoi le
rendu est correct mais dès qu'on arrive
dans la gamme dessus c'est meilleur les
écrans sont respectivement du cadre de
cette poussée du 5 25 pouces ça ça ne
change pas de toute façon dans toute
cette gamme hormis l'iphone disent les
dimensions d'écran sont standards du lcd
bien évidemment alors pour moi
l'iphone 7 est encore plus l'iphone
cette plus ce sont des appareils fait
pour la photo vous avez sur le sac un
appareil de 12 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de 1.8 donc forcément non plus
lumineux que ce qu'on peut retrouver
j'essaie l'iphone 6 aces sur le set plus
vous avez un grand-angle 12 mégapixels
avec l'ouverture de 1.8 et un
téléobjectif avec l'ouverture de 2.8
forcément appelée tel objectif sur cette
plus vous avez un zoom optique les zooms
numériques j'en parle pas vous allez
bouffer du pixel c'est pas terrible la
qualité au final le rendu est pas génial
donc il faut vraiment aller sur les
gammes plus pour avoir des zooms
optiques et surtout sur le set plus vous
avez le mode portrait qui a été pendant
longtemps en version d'état et qui
maintenant fonctionne vraiment bien
alors la caméra avant que sur le set 7
plus lui depuis de plus c'est une cette
méga pixels avec une ouverture de deux
points 2 bon allez pas chercher de la
qualité extraordinaire sur les caméras
avant d iphone pour passer quelques
coups de fil vidéo ça marche mais après
c'est pour faire des beaux selphy bon on
repassera il ya mieux quand même
ce qui est surprenant chez apple c'est
uniquement à partir d'un iphone 5 ou
comment savoir un produit qui est
résistant aux éclaboussures à l'eau et à
la poussière avec une certification ip67
et on parle même pas encore une
certification et puis 68 l'iphone
s'était vendu à 639 euros et c'est
exactement le même prix que l'iphone 6
aces plus nous très clairement n'achetez
pas l'iphone 6 aces plus aller
directement sur l'iphone 7,1 vous vivre
vraiment des grands écrans mais
fondamentalement suis là j'oublie et
l'iphone celle plus est vendu à 779
euros
d'ailleurs l'iphone set j'ai réalisé
aussi une vidéo c'est mon blog à berlin
[Musique]
alors il y avait un vrai traitement
derrière il ya de la colorimétrie donc
bon vous arrêtez pas là-dessus trouve
qu'il ya une vraie différence entre le 6
s pour l'avoir et avoir essayé le set
l'image est quand même beaucoup plus
belle mais pour moi si on veut vraiment
de la vidéo il faut aller sur le 8 et le
8 plus
[Musique]
tu es là
chose
alors en plus d'être le produit qu elles
mêmes caractéristiques techniques en
termes de processeurs en terme de
vitesse que l'iphone 10 l'iphone 8 et 8
plus permet d'abord de la réalité
augmentée permet de faire plein champ
c'est vraiment un modèle qui va pas
devenir obsolète trop vite alors ce qui
va ce qui risque de le rendre obsolète
c'est son design ce sont les même écran
que ce qu'on peut retrouver sur les 7,7
+ 6 aces 6 s plus mais sinon grosso modo
d'un point de vue purement techno à
l'intérieur performance c'est un produit
qui tient vraiment la route
je continue à schématiser c'est l'iphone
qui est fait vraiment pour la vidéo côté
photo vous avez sensiblement les mêmes
performances que vous retrouvez dans le
set
c'est plus pour la vidéo pour filmer en
4k et en full hd jusqu'à 60 images par
seconde
mais surtout ce qui fait la différence
c'est le slow motion 240 images par
seconde en full hd
alors qu avance sur les modèles
antérieurs sur le set plus et le set
vous pouviez filmer uniquement en 720p
c'était dommage donc séance a vraiment
que ce produit est optimisé pour la
vidéo vous avez aussi une stabilisation
optique de l'image ça c'est bien ça
évite d'avoir des choses qui tremblent
un peu trop alors après si effectivement
vous les livre des tremblements vous
invite à prendre un guide bollain comme
l'os mobile ça ce sera vraiment la
solution idéale
[Musique]
lorsqu'on parlait de caméra arrière de
l'iphone 8 plus ici et de l'iphone 6 est
ici il ya une vraie différence au niveau
de la lumière au niveau de pas mal de
choses
c'est normal quand même une vraie
différence entre les 8 plus et le 6 s
voilà un petit comparatif pour se rendre
compte le temps à tester la caméra de
face et là on compare les caméras de
phase là on est sur l'iphone 8 plus et
là on est sur l'iphone 6 s l'iphone 8
plus à un zoom optique comme l'iphone
cette plus enfin voilà donc tout ça je
schématise vraiment une fois de plus
l'iphone cette puce fonctionne aussi
bien pour la vidéo si ce n'est ce slow
motion qui est quand même un petit peu
moins bien en termes de définition vous
avez que du 720p l'iphone 8 vous pouvez
trouver à 809 euros tandis que l'iphone
8 plus vous trouverez à 919 euros
ce qui nous amène maintenant à l'iphone
ultime l'iphone 10 alors l'iphone dit
c'est vraiment le condensé des
meilleures choses qu'on peut trouver
chez apple
vous avez déjà un écran qui très beau un
écran oled 5,8 pouces de diagonale alors
vous avez tout ce qui va à l'intérieur
de sa défaite samedi toute la clique
sens on a mangé et on connaît vraiment
le côté technique de cet appareil là
vous avez le meilleur d'apple soit pour
la photo pour la vidéo
il est complètement optimisé par contre
il va falloir passer à la caisse
c'est sûr qu'une fois que vous l'avez
vous avez un appareil qui va être moins
désuet qui va moins se démolit vite par
rapport aux autres mais par contre il
faut aligner
côté photo vidéo je vous dis
sensiblement la même chose si ce n'est
que de tels objectifs ouvre en 2.4
d'ouvrir en deux points 8 par rapport à
la feuille 8 plus la stabilisation
optique est aussi différente lui il a
une double stabilisation optique
donc c'est vraiment l'iphone le plus
complet pour résumer l'iphone est ce
c'est l'iphone compact et vous n'avez
pas de grands besoins en termes de
photos et vidéos si ce n'est quelques
souvenirs l'iphone 6 s et si c'est plus
ça reste le produit moyen de gamme de
chez apple avec un plus grand écran par
rapport à l'iphone est ce pareil photo
vidéo ça fait le job mais c'est pas
extraordinaire des vous voulez avoir la
photo de meilleure qualité il faut
arriver sur le set mais surtout le
cèdent plus et de la vidéo optimisée 8
mais surtout le 8 plus si vous voulez
l'iphone ultime c'est l'iphone
dans tout ça lequel choisir à moins 1000
euros si vous voulez de belles photos et
belle vidéo moi ce que je vous conseille
c'est l'iphone cette plus si vous pouvez
vous permettre l'iphone nuit de plus
c'est encore mieux voilà c'est vraiment
ces deux produits qui pour moi sortiront
du lot par rapport au reste
après bien évidemment tout dépend de
votre budget c'est toujours une question
d'argent donc si vous voulez vraiment un
produit de chez apple
pas cher est ce et après sinon je vous
dise est plus fluide plus
et si vraiment vous avez de l'argent
pour votre anniversaire à noël pour
nouvel an on peut importe l'iphone 10 et
hop voilà un peu ce qu'on peut dire sur
ses iphone de 2018 dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez ce que vous avez des
iphone est ce que vous vous retrouvez
dans tout ce que je vous ai décrit est
ce que vous envisagez de partir chez
apple est ce que ça vous intéresse
est ce que vous trouvez que pour le prix
bas mieux vaut aller à la concurrence
parce que à prix égal souvent 12 ans des
technologies qui seront plus
intéressantes alors vous aurez
effectivement pas de pommes seront votre
smartphone mais vous aurez forcément des
produits qui vont être moins cher à
moins que vous allez sur le galaxy note
suite ou là forcément ben ça coûte aussi
un peu cher mais elle est produite chez
samsung sur tendance à baisser davantage
que les produits d'apple parce que apple
a vraiment une politique de prix à ses
hôtes et les baisses pas assez
rapidement donc vous mettez tout sans
commentaire moi je vous remercie d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo que j'habite à
l'essai des jolies plus je vous invite à
vous abonner
lorsqu'on parlera toujours toujours et
toujours plus de temps qu'avec plus
d'infos plus de nouveautés donc rester
connecté je vous dis à très bientôt vous
embrasse
et d'ici là soyez sages chaos
oui